welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today we are
discussing mental training and
visualization
mental training and visualization is a
fascinating process that has been shown
over and over again in now hundreds of
studies to improve our ability to learn
anything when I say anything I mean the
ability to learn music the ability to
learn and perform mathematics the
ability to learn and perform motor
skills in sport in dance across
essentially all domains the other
incredible thing about mental training
and visualization is that as you'll soon
see when you go into the literature that
is the scientific studies on mental
training and visualization you quickly
realize that it does not take a lot of
mental training and visualization in
order to get better at anything however
that mental training and visualization
has to be performed in a very specific
way and today we will discuss exactly
how to do mental training and
visualization in the specific ways that
allow it to complement the actual
performance of a motor or cognitive
skill to allow you to learn more quickly
and to consolidate that is to keep that
information in mind and body so that you
can perform those cognitive tasks music
tasks motor tasks etc for long periods
of time without ever forgetting how to
do them all of mental training and
visualization relies on what I consider
really the Holy Grail of our brain and
nervous system and that's
neuroplasticity neuroplasticity is our
nervous system which of course includes
the brain the spinal cord and all the
connections between the brain and spinal
cord and the organs and tissues of the
body and then all the neural connections
back from the organs and tissues of the
body to the brain and spinal cord so the
whole thing in both directions
has the ability to change in response to
experience in ways that are adaptive
that is that allows us to do things that
we could not do before and by doing
those things or by being able to perform
those mental operations we can do better
in the world that we live in we can
perform new tasks we can think new
thoughts we can come up with novel
solutions to pre-existing problems that
before really vexed us and that we
couldn't overcome all of that is
considered neuroplasticity so today what
I'm going to cover is a brief summary of
what neuroplasticity is that is how it
occurs in the brain and body this is
extremely important to understand if
you're going to use Mental training and
visualization then I'm going to talk
about what happens in our brain and body
when we do mental visualization in a
dedicated way many people have heard
perhaps that when you imagine something
happening that your brain doesn't know
the difference between that imagination
of the thing happening and the real
thing happening turns out that is not
true it is simply not true however there
is somewhat of an equivalence between a
real experience and an imagined
experience and we'll talk about the
difference between those and how that
can be leveraged in order to get the
most out of mental training and
visualization then I will cover exactly
which types of mental training and
visualization work best across all
domains meaning for Music Learning
mathematics
solving puzzles motor learning Sports
Performance
etc etc to really allow you a template
in which you can plug in or designate
what you're going to do each day for a
brief period of time in order to
accelerate your learning in whatever you
choose and then I'm going to go into a
bit of what happens in the brains of
different types of people these
different types of people that I'm
referring to are people who have more or
less of a natural ability to imagine
things and visualize them because it
turns out that we vary tremendously from
one individual to the next in terms of
our ability to mentally visualize and
imagine things and our ability to get
better at that over time and the good
news is anyone can get better at mental
training and visualization in ways that
can serve them well I'll also briefly
touch on the fact that certain people in
particular people on the autism spectrum
as well as people with synesthesias
which is the combining of different
perceptual experiences so you may be one
of these people or you may have heard of
people that for instance when they think
of a number they also just naturally
spontaneously think of a color and vice
versa we'll talk about how that relates
to mental imagery and visualization and
the creative process and problem solving
in general
and then finally what I'll do is I'll
recap mental training and visualization
from the standpoint of how best to apply
mental training and visualization
according to specific challenges things
like challenges with public speaking or
challenges with sports performance or
challenges with test taking Performance
challenges with essentially anything
that will allow you to build specific
mental training and visualization
practices that are brief that are
supported by Neuroscience studies and
that are highly effective before we
begin I'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
element element is an electrolyte drink
that has everything you need meaning
sodium magnesium and potassium but
nothing that you don't meaning no sugar
and it has the sodium magnesium
potassium in the ideal ratios for
hydrating and providing electrolytes to
the cells and tissues of your body so I
use element in my water when I wake up I
like to hydrate right away so I'll have
an element packet in about 16 to 32
ounces of water when I wake up I tend to
do the same while I exercise which I
typically do in the morning sometimes in
the afternoon and I'll drink another one
throughout the day the great thing about
element is also tastes terrific
I particularly like the watermelon
flavor but frankly I like all the
flavors just mixed into again about 16
to 32 ounces of water if you'd like to
try element you can go to drink element
lmnt.com huberman to claim a free
element sample pack with your purchase
again that's drink element lmnt.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by Maui Nui venison which I can
confidently say is the most nutrient
dense and delicious red meat available
Maui Nui spent nearly a decade building
a USDA certified wild harvesting system
to help balance deer populations on the
island of Maui the solution they built
is extremely powerful because it turns
the proliferation of an invasive species
into a wide range of nutrient dense
products from butcher Cuts so venison
steaks and ground venison Etc to organ
Meats bone broth and jerky I really love
all of their products so I love the
venison steaks and the ground venison
and their bone broth is fantastic it has
an unmatched 25 grams of protein per 100
calories so it's very high density High
high quality protein per calorie so if
you'd like to try Maui Nui venison go to
Maui Nui venison.com huberman to get 20
off your first order again that's Maui
News venison.com huberman to get 20 off
your first order today's episode is also
brought To Us by eight sleep eight sleep
makes Smart mattress covers with cooling
Heating and sleep tracking capacity I've
talked many times before on this podcast
about the fact that sleep is the
foundation of mental health physical
health and performance now one of the
key features to getting a good night's
sleep is making sure that you get the
temperature of the environment you sleep
in right
that's because in order to fall asleep
and stay deeply asleep throughout the
night your core body temperature needs
to drop by about one to three degrees
conversely in order to wake up in the
morning feeling refreshed and ready to
go your core body temperature needs to
go up by about one to three degrees of
course you can adjust the temperature of
the room that you sleep in I do hope
that people are doing that but adjusting
the temperature of your mattress and
your direct sleeping environment is also
key and with the eight sleep it makes it
very easy to program the temperature of
that mattress in a sleep environment not
just throughout the night but for
specific phases of the night I start
sleeping on an eight-sleep mattress
cover well over a year ago and it's the
best sleep that I've ever had if you'd
like to try eight sleep you can go do
eightsleep.com huberman and check out
the Pod Pro cover and save 150 at
checkout eight sleep currently ships in
the USA Canada UK select countries in
the EU and Australia again that's
eightsleep.com huberman to save 150 at
checkout let's talk about mental
training and visualization
now perhaps surprisingly mental training
visualization has been studied since the
late 1800s it's actually a paper
published in 1880 by Galton called the
statistics of mental imagery so long ago
people were quantifying and trying to
understand how is it that people come up
with mental images and how they can
apply that to learning things more
quickly and more stably over time
now as I mentioned earlier mental
training and visualization relies on a
process that we call neuroplasticity
neuroplasticity is a term that many
people have heard and encompasses many
different things so broadly speaking
neuroplasticity includes developmental
plasticity which is the sort of
plasticity that occurs between about
birth and age 25 and that can be
summarized very easily as passive
plasticity in other words the sorts of
changes that happen in one's nervous
system simply by engaging in the world
and experiencing Life as a child as a
young adult as an adolescent and as a 22
23 24 year old Etc now of course of
course of course it is not the case that
on your 25th birthday you close out
passive developmental plasticity and
start engaging in the other type of
neuroplasticity which is adult
neuroplasticity it's a gradual tapering
off of Developmental plasticity that
occurs between age zero and 25 and for
some people might occur somewhere around
26 for other people around 23
when we say 25 we're really just talking
about the average age in which passive
plasticity tapers off however starting
fairly early in adolescence and
extending all the way out into one's 80s
or 90s or hundreds should one live that
long is the other form of
neuroplasticity which is adult
neuroplasticity
adult neuroplasticity is very different
than developmental plasticity because it
is the sort of plasticity that one can
direct towards one's own specific
desired learning so if we wanted to get
a little bit technical here for sake of
clarity not for sake of confusion we
would say adult plasticity is really
about self-directed adaptive plasticity
and the reason we call it that as
opposed to something else where simply
adult plasticity is that there are many
different forms of neuroplasticy there
is for instance maladaptive
neuroplasticity that occurs if one gets
a really hard head hit and concussion
there will be changes to the brain and
nervous system but those changes to the
brain and nervous system do not allow it
to perform better in fact it often
impairs the brain and nervous system's
ability to function and therefore is
maladaptive so I don't want to get
overly wordy with a number of different
terms here but I do think it's important
to understand that we have developmental
plasticity again in which the brain and
nervous system changes simply in
response to experiencing specific things
for better or worse and there's adult
self-directed adaptive plasticity in
which one can direct specific changes in
terms of learning things cognitively or
learning things in terms of motor
function so sport Dance Etc or a
combination of the two now just to
really clarify what I mean by
developmental versus self-directed
adaptive plasticity I mentioned that
self-directed adaptive plasticity
actually can start in adolescence right
even though there's ongoing
developmental plasticity I mean let's be
really direct the brain of a 14 year old
is very different than the brain of that
same individual when that person is 21.
because there's ongoing developmental
plasticy however starting at about
adolescence we can all start to decide
what it is that we want to learn and
engage in self-directed adaptive
plasticity now the way to engage
self-directed adaptive plasticity
regardless of whether or not you're a 13
year old 14 year old or you're a 90 year
old or anywhere in between is that it
requires two things
the first thing it requires is focused
dedicated attention to the thing that
you're trying to learn that's the first
step and that actually triggers a number
of different chemical and electrical
prostheses in the brain that are often
associated with agitation and
frustration believe it or not the
agitation and frustration is a
reflection of the release of specific
chemicals in particular norepinephrine
and epinephrine also called
noradrenaline and adrenaline in the
brain and body that creates this
discomfort and this heightened level of
alertness and attention that many of us
don't like and tend to back away from
but it is exactly that chemical or I
should say neurochemical milieu which
signals to the neurons the nerve cells
in the brain and elsewhere in the body
that something needs to change because
if you think about it if you can do
something perfectly or if you try and do
something and it doesn't cause any
neurochemical change in your brain and
body well then there's no reason for
your brain and its connections with the
body to change in any particular way
okay so you need focused dedicated
attention to the thing that you're
trying to learn it's off often
accompanied by agitation frustration Etc
so that's perfectly normal in fact
that's a signal that things are going
right meaning they're headed towards
learning but there's a second component
that's really required for self-directed
adaptive plasticity and that's periods
of deep rest in particular a good
night's sleep in particular on the night
that follows that focused attention to
the thing you're trying to learn there
are now hundreds of studies in both
animal models and in humans showing that
it is really during sleep and other
states of deep relaxation things like
meditation and non-sleep deep rest which
I've talked about before on this podcast
but really during our main night of
sleep that the rewiring of neural
connections that is the actual
neuroplasticity takes place so the verb
neuroplasticity the rearrangement of
connections between neurons really
occurs during sleep in particular on the
first night following an attempt to
learn something through this focused
attention now developmental plasticity
which is passive also requires good
sleep sleep it's slightly different or
frankly it's a lot different in terms of
the underlying mechanisms than
self-directed adaptive plasticity but
because today we're mainly talking about
how to learn faster through mental
training and visualization and that
really Maps more closely onto
self-directed adaptive plasticity I just
really want to emphasize this two-step
process there has to be focused
dedicated attention and then there needs
to be sleep and in particular sleep on
the first night following that training
now should you have the unfortunate
experience of getting woken up in the
middle of the night following trying to
learn something or should you simply not
be able to sleep for whatever reason on
the night following a bout of learning
or an attempt to learn do not despair
because it turns out that there are what
are called second and third night
effects also once you sleep you will
learn those neuroplastic events the
reordering of connections that we call
synapses and the changes that occur in
neural circuits that reflects what we
call self-directed adaptive plasticity
that still will occur her but ideally
you got a great night's sleep on the
first night following trying to learn
and the second night and the third and
so on and so on now there are a few
other things that are critical to
understand about self-directed adaptive
plasticity that will become especially
important when thinking about protocols
for developing the ideal mental training
and visualization process for you and
that is that there are different forms
of plasticity that occur between neurons
although the two main forms are what are
called long-term potentiation and
long-term depression I just want to cue
up right now that the word depression is
a very loaded word because the moment
people hear the word depression they
think oh no that's bad
but in the case of neuroplasticity
long-term depression is simply a change
in the connections between neurons and
the excitability between neurons that in
many ways can be excellent for learning
things in particular motor skills and
we'll get into this in more detail in a
little bit but it turns out that a lot
of our ability to get better at some
sort of motor skill involves this thing
that we call long-term depression and
that's because much of what is happening
when we learn a new motor skill is that
we are depressing or suppressing
specific actions in order to generate a
very specific coordinated action
some of the best examples of long-term
depression can actually be borrowed from
developmental plasticity so for instance
if you've ever sat across from an infant
who is trying to eat their meal so
imagine a one and a half year old or a
two-year-old trying to eat some noodles
or some soup or any kind of baby
suitable food with a spoon and they're
holding the spoon or they're trying to
hold the spoon what you'll notice is
that their motor movements are terribly
uncoordinated
they often will take that spoon to their
cheek or to their eye to their head
we've all seen these very amusing photos
of babies with bowls of food on their
head or with food all over their face or
just everywhere it's appears that
they're basically getting the food
everywhere except where it's supposed to
go which is in their mouth and that's
because their motor movements are not
very well coordinated at that age and
they're not very well coordinated not
because they lack sufficient numbers of
neural connection synapses between
neurons but rather because they have too
many connections between too many
different neurons the neural circuits
that control very dedicated coordinated
movement are not there yet instead too
many neurons are connected to too many
other neurons and so they can't generate
the precise movements that are required
in order to get that spoon to their
mouth now over time they get better at
moving the utensil to their mouth
such that hopefully by about age five or
six they are eating you know in a
relatively cleaner way and hopefully by
time they're 10 or 11 or 12 they're
getting the food into their mouth and
not all over their face people learn
this to varying degrees all you have to
do is go to a restaurant and watch how
people eat
um and you will see a vast variation in
people's coordinated movements with
utensils but in general there's a theme
the younger the person the more
uncoordinated their movement of utensils
and as they get older the more
coordinated now of course in people that
are very old they have challenges moving
objects
and their limbs in very smooth ways and
that has to do with a topic that we'll
get into when we talk about age-related
cognitive decline and motor related
dementias but for sake of today's
discussion if you just want to think
about what happens with long-term
depression and the development of a
motor skill both as a baby as an
adolescent and as an adult when you're
trying to learn a new motor skill is
that you are eliminating incorrect
movements and when you are eliminating
incorrect movements to arrive at only
the correct movements in a very
reflexive and repeated way so think your
golf swing your tennis serve I think
serving a volleyball think a child
learning to crawl and then walk think a
child learning to eat with utensils an
example I gave before what's happening
in all of those cases is that yes
certain Connections in the brain are
being strengthened or what we call
potentiated they are undergoing
long-term potentiation the so-called
quote unquote fire together wired
together Mantra that was popularized by
the great neurobiologist Dr Carla Schatz
my colleague at Stanford
but in addition to that long-term
depression the quieting or the silencing
of specific synapses that is connections
between neurons is absolutely critical
for motor skill learning so we have ltp
long-term potentiation and LTD long-term
depression is every bit as important as
ltp long-term potentiation for getting
better at some sort of motor skill and
indeed it getting better at some sort of
cognitive skill now as we hear this this
should be intuitive to all of us if you
look at somebody's attempt to learn a
particular dance step or at somebody's
attempt to do a tennis serve the first
time it's all over the place now it's
not perhaps all over the place in that
they're doing a jumping jack while
trying to serve the tennis ball but
they're generally arcing the racket too
widely on one trial and then they're
arcing it too close to their body on the
next trial so if we were to draw a line
over each one of those trials we would
see that there were lines everywhere
over time whereas once they quote
unquote affect the tennis serve it's
going to be line drawn directly over
line draw and directly over line meaning
the Arc of that tennis serve is going to
be very restricted and that without
question has reflected the removal or
the quieting of particular synapses
connections between neurons in the brain
and body to allow that very narrow
coordinated and directed movement the
same is true for learning anything in
the cognitive domain meaning if you are
to learn a language
it is not of course the case that you
know every word in that language and
then you simply remove certain words and
arrive at the correct sentence structure
that you're trying to achieve but rather
you have to suppress your native
language or if you're a young child you
have to suppress the generation of just
kind of random babbling sounds turns out
babbling isn't random at all but the
point is that you have to suppress
the enunciation of particular sounds and
direct the pronunciation of other sounds
in order to generate that new language
or your ability to speak at all okay so
we can really think about
neuroplasticity as both a building up
process in which you increase connection
so-called long-term potentiation and a
sculpting down or a removal of
connections process that we're going to
call long-term depression now I have to
acknowledge that of course there are
other forms of neuroplasticity too I
know there are probably some aficionados
listening to this
who will be perhaps shouting back at uh
whatever device my voice is coming out
of wait what about Spike timing
dependent plasticity or what about
paired pulse facilitation yes yes and
yes there are multiple forms of
communication between neurons that can
strengthen those connections or weaken
those connections but for today's
discussion we just broadly want to think
about long-term potentiation and
long-term depression because it captures
the two most important themes related to
mental training and visualization which
is that when we perform a given
cognitive or physical task in the real
world so we actually try the dance step
or the tennis serve or when we actually
try a math problem or we try and learn
some specific knowledge and write it
down and remember it
that is engaging particular neurons
right they're firing they're releasing
chemicals
but it is also actively suppressing the
activity of other neurons and we are
always completely unaware of the ways in
which our brain is suppressing certain
activity okay so today we have to keep
in mind that where there is
strengthening of connections there is
also weakening of connections and when
it comes to mental training and
visualization and here's the really key
point with mental training and
visualization you are capturing both
processes both the potentiation that is
the building up and strengthening of
connections and the weakening of the
connections that are inappropriate for
the thing you're trying to learn and
there are different aspects of mental
training and visualization protocols
that really harness the potentiation
versus the depression aspect and today
we will cover mental training and
visualization protocols that capture
both the potentiation and the depression
aspect of neuroplasticity and in that
way serve as an augment that is a
complement to the actual real world
cognitive and physical training that
you're doing because I'll just give this
away right now turns out that mental
training and visualization is not a
replacement for real-world cognitive or
motor Behavior
again mental training and visualization
cannot replace
real world execution of cognitive tasks
or of motor tasks if you want to learn
however mental training and
visualization can and has been shown to
be effective for greatly enhancing the
speed at which you learn and the
stability of that learning over time
okay so let's take a second and really
think about what's happening in the
brain and body when we do mental
training or visualization in fact we can
do a little experiment right now that is
not unlike many of the classic
experiments looking at what's happening
in the brain and body through mental
training and visualization in which I
just ask you to close your eyes and
imagine a yellow Cube okay and next to
that yellow cube is a red rose
and perhaps I also ask you to
float or fly up above the cube and the
rows and look at them from the top
down
and then I tell you to fly back around
and land behind those and look at them
from the perspective of behind that
yellow Cube and that red rose okay now
what the data tell us is that most
people will be able to do that most of
you will be able to do that to some
degree or another regardless of your
attention span whether or not you have
ADHD or not most of you will be able to
do that to some degree or another we
also know from neuroimaging studies in
which people are placed into a
functional magnetic resonance imaging
scanner that during the sort of
visualization you just did or that I
described that your visual cortex and
Associated areas quote unquote light up
they become very active in similar but
not identical ways to how they would
light up and be activated were you to
actually look at a yellow cube and a red
rose on a screen and perhaps Fly Above
them virtually of course and land behind
them virtually of course or if you were
to actually look at a yellow Cube and
red rose in the real world right in
front of you on a table then you know
get up on your tippy toes and look down
on them from the top and then walk
around the table and look at them from
the other side so there is some degree
of what we call perceptual equivalence
between real world experiences digital
experiences and imagined meaning with
our eyes closed just in our Mind's Eye
experiences
this is true not just of vision and what
we call the visual domain but also the
auditory domain okay so for instance I
could play for you a short motif of a
song Let's just pick something that I
think most people know goodness I'm a
terrible musician and even worse um
singer but let's just take the the
opening to AC DC's Back in Black right I
think I can do that when it's like
[Music]
okay got it
that's the actual sound although
admittedly a dreadful version of of the
great AC DC song Back in Black but now I
ask you to close your eyes or we could
keep them open and just imagine that
okay
or for instance I
place you in a quiet room so you close
your eyes and ask you to imagine the
opening to AC DC's black and black but
ask you to pause it halfway through what
you would find again is that most people
somewhere between 90 and 95 of people
would be able to do all the sorts of
things I described right Cube and Rose
ACD Back in Black
even a somatosensory task I imagine you
need to imagine what it's like to touch
felt or to touch chinchilla hair or
something like that H Chinchilla's hair
ideally a live chinchilla sitting still
those little critters move really really
fast but they have very very soft hair
High hair density so soft
okay most people can do that
about five to fifteen percent of people
are less able to do that and there's a
small percentage of people in that five
to fifteen percent
that simply cannot do it at all that
just cannot visualize well we'll talk
later about these people they have
what's called aphantasia an inability to
mentally visualize but most people are
actually pretty good at visualizing
things when they are told what to
visualize and and this is a really key
point and if what they are told to
visualize is very simple and the whole
visualization is quite brief lasting on
the order of about 15 seconds to
generate the visualization in the
auditory or in the visual aspect of
one's Minds I or ear if you will
and if it's repeated over and over
what's far harder for everybody to do
and in fact what most people simply
cannot do is Imagine long extended
scenes and stories in their mind that go
on for minutes and minutes that involve
a lot of different sensory stimuli this
is a really key point in fact as we
start to hone in on ideal mental
training and visualization protocols I'd
like to establish this as the first
principle of mental training and
visualization which is that if you are
going to use Mental training and
visualization to its best effect in
order to engage in neuroplasticity and
learning you need to keep those
visualizations quite brief really on the
order of about 15 to 20 seconds or so
and pretty darn sparse meaning not
including a lot of elaborate
visualization not including a lot of
sequences of motor steps what I mean are
motor sequences if you're trying to
learn something in terms of physical
movement
or visual sequences or auditory
sequences if you're trying to learn
things in terms of music or Dance Etc
that can be completed and repeated in 15
seconds or less
now later I'll give you a couple of
specific examples but if you want to use
Mental training and visualization
understand this is the key first
principle they have to be very short
visualizations that you can repeat over
and over and over again with a high
degree of accuracy so you don't want to
embark on a mental training and
visualization Paradigm in which it
involves a lot of elaborate stimuli and
you have to think really hard and work
really hard even if you're in that
category of people who can do mental
visualization pretty naturally and
easily now if you're somebody who can't
do mental visualization in fact if
you're somebody who has full-blown
aphantasia or the inability to mentally
visualize well then it's especially
important that you make those mental
trainings and visualizations really
brief and very very simple I'd like to
take a quick break and acknowledge one
of our sponsors athletic greens athletic
greens now called ag1 is a vitamin
mineral probiotic drink that covers all
of your foundational nutritional needs
I've been taking athletic greens since
2012 so I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring podcast the reason I started
taking athletic greens and the reason I
still take athletic greens once are
usually twice a day is that it gets to
be the probiotics that I need for gut
health our gut is very important it's
populated by gut microbiota that
communicate with the brain the immune
system and basically all the biological
systems of our body to strongly impact
our immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 now in
order to develop the best mental
training and visualization protocols for
you let's go a little bit deeper into
what the research says about mental
visualization now the classic work on
mental visualization really hinges on a
number of different researchers and
their work but in particular Roger
Shepard who did this work at Stanford
and Stephen coslin who's now at Harvard
of course others in the field but it's
really the work of Shepherd the lay the
foundation for our understanding of what
happens in the brain when we mentally
visualize something
Shepard did these incredible experiments
in which he had students mentally
visualize simple objects like a square
like a triangle and he measured how long
it took them to do that now of course at
the time when he did these experiments
there were no sophisticated brain
Imaging devices and machines like fmri
however everything I'm about to describe
has been later confirmed using things
like fmri what Shepard did and what he
found is that if people were told to
visualize very simple objects they did
it pretty quickly however if they were
told to visualize more complex objects
or importantly to rotate those objects
in their Mind's Eye well then it took
longer for them to perform those mental
visualizations now many of you might
think duh if I have to just imagine a
triangle or a cube that's going to be
very easy and very fast whereas if I
have to rotate that triangular cube in
my mind's eye that's going to take more
time and indeed that is somewhat of a
duh except and this is so very important
except that what Shepard and his
colleagues found is that how long it
takes somebody to generate and rotate a
given visual image
scales directly with the complexity of
that image in fact causalin did some
experiments I think illustrate this even
better and here's the experiment I love
this experiment I think you'll love it
too because
it illustrates something so
fundamentally important about how our
brains work not just for sake of mental
training and visualization which is how
our brains work at all
he showed people a picture of a map so a
map drawn on a piece of paper
this was a map of an island
it included things like a loading dock
for some boats it had a location for
getting food on the island at some trees
add some other small landmarks drawn out
and people looked at this
and memorized it or in other experiments
they just had people imagine this island
and the location of these different
landmarks on the island so it didn't
really matter which but then he had
people imagine moving or walking from
one location on the island to another so
they'd say okay you're at the loading
dock now move to the restaurant okay
you're at the restaurant now move to the
palm tree you're on the North Shore of
the island now go around the side of the
island clockwise to arrive at the bay on
the southwest corner this sort of thing
what causlin found was absolutely
incredible what he found was that the
amount of time that it takes people to
move from one location on the map to
another
scaled linearly directly with the actual
physical location between those objects
on the map so for those of you that can
understand or into the importance of
what Shepard and causlin showed great
I'm guessing however that for most
people out there you're still grasping
like okay interesting you know how
things happen in the real world dictates
how they happen in our mind's eye but I
want to make sure that I really nail
home the importance of this for
everybody
the importance of this is that when we
look at something in the real world so
if I look at the pen in front of me I'm
holding up my pen for those of you that
are listening just holding up my pen in
front of me I move it to the right and
back and forth what's happening is I'm
activating or I'm triggering the
electrical activity of neurons which we
can think of kind of as pixels in my eye
okay so it's leftward to right word
motion for me and back and forth and
those are getting activated and they're
sending signals up to my visual cortex
and that information is processed at a
given speed
what the visualization experiments that
Shepard and koslin and others did show
is that the processing speed of imagined
experiences is exactly the same as the
processing speed of real experiences and
the spatial relationship between
imagined and real experiences
is exactly the same as well put simply
when we imagine something in our mind's
eye or mind's ear
we are Imagining the real thing
happening and when I say the real thing
it's not the obvious real thing of
course if you're imagining something
that's the thing you're imagining what I
mean is that your brain at the level of
neurons is behaving exactly the same way
and this needn't have been the case okay
there could have been a result for
instance that if people were asked to
visualize a cube and rotate it
from you know flip it from top to bottom
okay so put the top that's upward on a
table now down on the table and so forth
or to migrate around the island you know
counterclockwise going from you know the
northern coast all the way down to the
southern coast clockwise and then back
up to the northern coast that they could
have just done it really quickly like
all in one second but that's not what
happens they always match the speed at
which they do things in their Mind's Eye
to the same speed that they do them in
the real world so in telling you this
what I'm saying is that mental
visualization at the neural level is
identical to real world events so when
you've heard that when we imagine
something it's identical in terms of our
brain's experience of it and our bodies
experience of it as when we actually
experience something that is true at the
neural level however when it comes to
learning and improving performance in
the cognitive or physical domain they
are not equivalent so this is the second
principle of of mental training and
visualization as you recall the first
principle of mental training and
visualization was that in order to make
it effective it needs to be very brief
and very simple and repeated over and
over again the second principle of
mental training and visualization is
that while yes mental training and
visualization recaptures the same
patterns of neural firing in the exact
same ways as real world behavior and
thinking
it is not as effective as real world
behavior and thinking in other words if
you want to learn something the ideal
situation is to combine real training in
the physical world with mental training
and I'll talk about exactly how to do
that and in what ratios a little bit
later now there's a really incredible
set of experiments that illustrate why
it is that mental training and
visualization can be extremely effective
but that it's always going to be most
effective when combined with real world
training and experiences the experiments
that I'm talking about involve the use
of what are called bistable images or
impossible figures now some of you are
probably familiar with impossible
figures these are figures or objects
that when you look at them
they have these odd features like you're
not sure where they stop and where they
start where they end one good example
would be the so-called Mobius strip the
Mobius strip is literally a strip or a
line that is contiguous it goes up and
it loops around and then it curves
around and then it goes back and and it
just continues and continues and when
you look at it you can never really tell
where it starts and where it stops
because it doesn't have any of the
features that allow you to see what's
the front and what's the back in any
kind of stable way another example of an
impossible figure would be you know a
little set of Cubes that look like
they're coming out toward you maybe with
a little Bend in them going up at a
right angle perhaps but then if you look
at it a little bit longer that little
piece that's facing up looks like it's
in front and you can't really tell
what's in front and what's in back and
so it's called an impossible figure
because you don't really know how to
frame it in your mind to tell what's
closer to you and what's further apart
bi-stable images are somewhat similar
although different in the sense that
they typically are simple Silhouettes so
for instance the faces vases by stable
image is perhaps the most famous of
these where you look at this image it's
very simple and it looks like two vases
but then you look at it a little bit
longer and you realize that you're
looking at the side angle or the profile
of two faces looking at one another and
when you see those two faces looking at
one another you can't see the vases at
the same time but then if you decide to
see the vases again you can see the
vases again but the faces disappear so
it's bi-stable meaning that you can't
see the faces and bases at the same time
and impossible figures and bi-stable
images
are capturing the fact that your visual
cortex and some of the associated areas
that compute visual scenes in your world
are essentially trying to recreate
whatever it is that's out in front of
them and that's effectively what your
visual system does it's very good at
recreating visual images in your brain
in your mind's eye because if you think
about it even with your eyes open your
brain is just creating an abstract
representation of what it thinks is out
there
but that when it comes to assigning an
identity to something like oh that's a
face or oh that's a vase
that is constrained by different neural
circuits by different areas of the brain
and somehow those circuits can't be
co-active we cannot see the faces and
the vases at exactly the same time we
can switch back and forth really quickly
just as we can switch back and forth
really quickly when we're looking at the
impossible figure and think okay that's
the front of it that's the back no wait
that's the back that's the front end
it's going back and forth but we can't
see them both at the same time no one
can see them both at the same time
okay we know this from brain Imaging
studies now impossible figures in
bi-stable images can be seen right you
could look them up right now on your
phone or computer
or I could show you pictures of them on
paper right in front of you and you can
do these sorts of perceptual experiments
of telling people look at the face look
at the vase look at the front of the
cube and I'll make it at the back of the
cube and they can do this somewhat
deliberately
however and this is I think so very
interesting to understanding how mental
training and visualization does and does
not support Real World Learning
if you try to imagine a bi-stable image
you can't do it
in fact no one can do it until they do
something else okay so for those of you
saying wait I can do it I can do faces
faces in my mind's eye I promise you
that the neuroimaging
disputes your belief okay and supports
the idea that we can see real world by
stable images we can see real world
impossible figures but when we try and
imagine those in our Mind's Eye we
simply can't do it we can't do the
perceptual shift in our Mind's Eye we
can't switch back and forth between
faces and vases however and I just have
to chuckle because I think these
experiments are so clever if I have you
trace or Draw
with a pen
on a piece of paper an impossible figure
or the faces vases by stable image and
then I ask you to imagine that bi-stable
image or impossible figure and to switch
back and forth
you were able to do it so what that
illustrates is that it's the combination
of imagined and real world experiences
real motor movements real perceptual
experiences combined with motor
movements combined with what you imagine
in your mind's eye that really gives you
the most depth and flexibility over your
mental visualization
and in doing so we can really stamp down
a third principle of mental training and
visualization which is that your mental
training and visualization will be far
more effective if you are performing the
exact same or very similar mental and
physical tasks in the real world okay so
first principle is mental training and
visualization needs to be simple and
brief and repeated second is that mental
training and visualization is not a
replacement for real world
motor training or cognitive training
it's an augment it's an addition that
can really help and the third principle
of mental training and visualization is
that you need to combine mental training
and visualization with real world
behaviors and experiences that are very
very similar now as a brief but I think
really relevant aside
one of the things that also makes mental
training and visualization more
effective is when we assign cognitive
labels to what's going on when we
visualize so what I mean is that people
are much better at manipulating faces
and bases in their Mind's Eye of course
only once they've drawn them out
physically with their hand as I
mentioned before then they are
manipulating abstract objects like
impossible figures
in part because
by labeling them faces and vases
people are able to capture a lot of
other neural Machinery that's related to
faces and bases in fact we have entire
brain areas on both sides of the brain
devoted to the processing of faces
they're called fusiform face area
we have other areas in our brain that
are involved in processing of 3D objects
but faces are of particular value
there's a there's a value to
understanding what a face is as opposed
to a non-face and there's a value to
understanding what a particular face is
in fact the simplest way to put this is
that the human brain is in many ways a
face recognition and expression of faces
recognition machine it of course does
other things but it is exceptionally
good at that unless you're in a
profession in which the relationships
between 3D objects and your ability to
manipulate them is exceedingly important
you're not going to have a lot of neural
real estate specifically devoted to that
some people will be better at it some
people will be worse but when it comes
to faces unless you have a condition
like prophetsagnosia which is an
inability to recognize say famous faces
and distinguish them from non-famous
phases or if you have some sort of face
recognition deficit which about anywhere
from one perhaps to three percent of
people out there have yeah they're just
terrible recognizing faces and by the
way there's about half a percent of
people out there that are what are
called super recognizers that can
recognize faces in a large crowd they
can recognize specific faces even from
just partial profiles by the way these
people are extremely valuable to
security agencies and security agencies
are very good at finding these people
um machines are quickly getting
better or at least as good as super
recognizers but the best super
recognizers are still better than the
best AI and machine algorithms out there
but the point is that in your mind's eye
you are better able to manipulate
specific objects or to see things more
clearly and with more specificity when
it has a label that you recognize from
your real world experience as opposed to
abstract or fictional labels okay again
stamping home the idea that what you
experience in the real world really
serves to support your mental imagery
and therefore the key importance of
experiencing and doing things in the
real world and supporting that with
mental training and visualization and
not just relying on mental training and
visualization and the tangent here
that's a little bit of fun
and I don't think we've ever talked
about before on this podcast is that of
UFOs unidentified flying objects you
know there's a lot of people out there
who think that they've seen UFOs I guess
technically they have because a UFOs and
identified flying object and if it's
unidentified at least to them then it is
indeed a UFO I guess the question is
whether or not uh or the dispute rather
is whether or not those UFOs are
actually flown by aliens or controlled
by aliens I think that's where the
dispute lies but you can imagine how if
somebody sees an object in their
environment and decides Ah that's a UFO
okay remember these faces faces or these
impossible figures if they say oh that
thing is a UFO as opposed to something
else they see in other words the face
not the vase well that stamps it down as
a memory in their visual system and
related systems and then in their Mind's
Eye they are seeing the UFO they're not
seeing the other thing that it could
possibly be okay so it's stamped down a
very specific memory so the point here
is that mental training and
visualization relies on not just the
physical Contours and the exact spatial
profiles and the speed of movement of
particular things that we experience in
the real world it also heavily depends
on the cognitive labels and the
decisions we make about the things that
we see and this will become very
important as we build up toward our
fourth principle of mental training and
visualization which is that our
cognitive labels that is what we decide
is happening when we do mental training
and visualization turns out to be very
important now this is not simply to say
that you can decide okay I want to learn
how to play piano and so I'm going to
tell myself that a particular chord I
imagine in my mind's eye is identical to
the real world chord just because I
decide it is the brain doesn't work that
way it's not possible to just lie to
yourself and learn better as a
consequence of the lies you tell
yourself however
what this tells us is that it is very
very important that your mental training
and visualization accurately
recapitulate the real world training
that you're doing so if we are going to
stamp down a fourth principle of
effective mental training and
visualization based on what we know from
the scientific literature
is that your mental training and
visualization should assign labels to
what you're doing that can be matched to
real world training and experiences now
these can be somewhat abstract so for
instance if you're trying to learn
a particular aspect of the golf swing
okay so let's say that you're working on
your golf swing seems to be there are a
lot of people out there working on their
golf swing and you're going to do some
mental training and visualization in
order to improve your golf swing we
already know again let's just March
through them that your mental training
and visualization needs to be brief and
simple it needs to be the same or in
fact it will be we can say the same as
your real world golf swing in other
words it will take you exactly the same
amount of time to perform that golf
swing in your mind's eye as it would in
the real world incredible right again
something that maybe is taking a little
bit of time to sink in but once it does
you're gonna be like wow the brain is
really an incredible machine
and that third principle that you still
have to do golf swings in the real world
in addition to the mental training of
golf swings and fourth that if you want
that mental training and visualization
to really improve your golf swing you're
going to have to name or apply an
identity to the specific golf swing or
aspect of the golf swing that you're
practicing so this could be abstract you
could call it mental training and
visualization of golf swing 1A and you
can imagine your mind's eye you know the
perfect golf swing over and over and
over and over but then when you're in
the real world you're also going to have
to call that
either out loud or just to yourself golf
swing 1A okay as opposed to a putt which
might be 1B so naming and giving an
identity
to a real world skill and applying the
same name or identity to the mental
version of that the visualization of
that can enhance the mental training and
visualization in significant ways so
when we apply identities or names to
these mental trainings and
visualizations and again provide that
they are brief and repeated and so on
we greatly enhance the amount of neural
Machinery in the brain and body that we
are able to recruit when we go to
perform those
real world golf swings and golf putts
and here just replace golf swing and
golf butt with anything that you're
trying to learn
you're able to recruit a lot more neural
machinery and greatly increase the
probability of proper execution so
before we go any further I want to share
with you a couple of incredible aspects
of mental visualization that really can
be harnessed and applied toward mental
training and visualization some of these
were done by Roger Shepard and his
graduate students in postdocs some were
done by Steve costlin and by others what
these experiments really show is that
mental training and visualization is
capturing many many of the exact same
features of real world behavior and
perceptions not all of them but many of
them so for instance if I tell you to
close your eyes
and imagine
a ceiling that has tiles that are black
and white checkered tiles you know one
black tile one white tile for instance
we know based on experiments where we
measure eye movements Behind Closed
eyelids is that people tend to move
their eyes up when they are imagining
things above them such as the ceiling
whereas if I tell you to imagine things
down on the floor like you're taking a
hike and you're looking for rattlesnakes
actually just recently I experienced
because it's spring here in California
rattlesnake along a hiking trail it's
really quite beautiful although I have
to confess I enjoyed keeping my distance
I don't like snakes uh very much I don't
dislike snakes but I prefer not to
interact with them unless I have to if I
have you imagine that rattlesnake
depending on your relationship or
thoughts about rattlesnakes number of
things will happen in your brain of
course activation in the limbic system
or not for instance
but what I know is that regardless of
how you feel about snakes
most of you will move your eyes down
when imagining a snake okay it might be
subtle it might be fast but
statistically that result shows up as
opposed to when I imagine or I ask you
to imagine something above you you tend
to move your eyes up in addition to that
if I tell you for instance to imagine an
elephant and a mouse next to one another
you presumably have some real world
understanding about the relative sizes
of elephants versus mice elephants
generally are bigger than mice thank
goodness
mice are smaller than elephants if I ask
you to tell me about the details of that
Mouse's face so for instance can you see
its whiskers
the processing time required for you to
do that is much longer than the
processing time required if I say
tell me what the position of that
elephant's trunk is now why would that
be so okay the position of the
elephant's trunk wasn't something that I
told you it wasn't dictated by me it's
in your mind's eye maybe you don't even
know and you have to go searching for it
but what we do know is that if I tell
you to look at a small object in your
mind's eye versus a larger object so for
instance the mouse versus the elephant
it takes longer for you to do that in
other words just as with the map
experiment the distance between things
on a map is conserved in your mind's eye
as a linear relationship takes longer to
go far distances between things on a map
in your mind
than it does to go shorter distances
it's also the case that it takes you
longer to look at the details of a small
object versus a large object because why
because you are zooming in in your
mind's eye again all of which speaks to
the equivalence of mental imagery with
real world imagery and perception and as
I mentioned earlier and as we'll see in
a moment this also extends into the
motor domain it takes you longer to
perform Complex Motor sequences in your
mind's eye than it does simple motor
sequences just as it would in the real
world and if you're saying of course of
course of course well then great then
we've really underscored the point which
is that when you imagine things it is
not exactly the same but it is very very
much the same as actually doing or
perceiving those things in the real
world and the fifth principle of
effective mental training and
visualization is this notion of
equivalence of mental imagery versus
Real World perception and behavior
these are the experiments as you recall
where if people are told to look for
clouds in their mental visualization
they tend to look up or if they're
looking for something on the floor they
tend to look down even Behind Closed
eyelids now this can be applied toward
building an especially effective mental
training and visualization protocol if
you deliberately move your eyes in the
direction of the thing or things that
you are trying to recapitulate in your
mind in your visualization that is you
don't necessarily have to include this
step but mental training and
visualization is going to be more
effective if you do because with
consciously generated eye movements
again even Behind Closed eyelids you are
bringing about more of the neural
circuitry that one would experience if
you were to perform that particular
cognitive task or motor task in the real
world which as I mentioned before in
principle number three you need to be
doing anyway separately from your rental
training and visualization so what we're
talking about here is thus far five
principles of mental training and
visualization that are well established
from the scientific research literature
in fact I haven't mentioned this quite
yet and I'll refer to some other
references but there's a wonderful
systematic review of a large number of
studies that have looked at mental
training and visualization what's
effective what's less effective across a
bunch of different disciplines that
include education medicine music
psychology and sports we will provide a
link to this paper in the show note
captions but the title of the paper is
best practice for motor imagery a
systematic literature view on motor
imagery training elements in five
different disciplines as the title
suggests it's mainly for
motor imagery training but it extends
into music which of course involves
motor training and execution but as well
as education this review establishes a
number of different important things I'm
going to read off some of the key or
highlight takeaways for instance I
described principle one of effective
mental training and visualization which
is that the visualization be brief and
it be simple and it be repeated you may
ask how many times that very brief 5 to
15 second exercise of going through some
routine
should be repeated
well different Studies have used
different ranges of let's call them
repetitions in a given training session
but the number that seems to be most
effective is somewhere between 50 and 75
repeats per session
that brings about the question of how
long one should rest between each repeat
this gets a little tricky depending on
what you're trying to do remember that
we have this threshold of about 15
seconds for completion of the entire
motor sequence let's say what you're
trying to do like a golf swing takes you
five seconds to imagine in your mind's
eye
from the point where you let's just say
have the ball on the tee you bring the
the golf club up you might reposition
your your feet just a little bit you
know that kind of a little wiggle that
golf golfers do and then the swing if
that whole thing takes five seconds in
your mind's eye and roughly five seconds
in the real world well then you'd be
able to repeat it of course three times
in 15 seconds that would be one
repetition even though you're doing it
three times so it's one 15 second Epoch
as it's sometimes called Epoch Epoch and
then you would rest for an approximately
equivalent amount of time 15 seconds or
so and then repeat
and the rest 15 seconds or so and then
repeat
rest 15 seconds and then repeat again
three golf swings within that 15 seconds
rest 15 seconds three golf swings within
that 15 seconds rest 15 seconds truth
told these epochs and these rest periods
do not need to be exact you could
imagine for instance that you get three
repetitions of the Swing within 14
seconds well then do you do another one
or do you wait until the end of that 15
seconds I encourage you not to obsess
too much about those sorts of points
rather you want to do as many repeats as
you can in about a 15 second
Epoch and then rest for about 15 seconds
and then repeat for a total of 50 to 75
repetitions which might not sound like a
lot to some of you might sound like an
awful lot to others of you to me it
sounds like a lot you know 50
repetitions of something and where
you're trying to concentrate in your
mind's eye on getting something
accomplished over and over over again in
exactly the same way might seem like a
lot we know based on the learning
literature that your ability to
successfully perform something in the
real world will lend itself to better
performance of that thing in the
imagined world within your mind's eye
that's also one of these sort of does
but if you're trying to get better at
something that you've never performed
before you really should know that the
mental training visualization is
probably not the best augment
to that real world training until you're
able to perform it successfully in the
real world at least some of the time
mental training and visualization can be
effective however at increasing the
accuracy or the frequency at which you
can do that real world Behavior
so if normally you're only getting the
correct swing or you're only hitting the
the golf ball correctly
say 10 of the time mental training and
visualization can really help bring that
number up but it is important that you
are able to successfully complete that
motor task in the real world similarly
for performance of cognitive tasks so
say for instance um speaking a new
language you might ask well gosh what
what in the landscape of speaking a new
language can be restricted to 5 to 15
seconds where I could repeat it anywhere
from you know through one to three times
in a given Epoch and then rest and then
keep repeating 50 to 75 times Well there
I would encourage you to pick something
that you are able to do perhaps very
slowly so to speak a particular sentence
but with some challenge in getting the
accent and the enunciation right but
you've completed it successfully before
and you want to get more smooth or more
fluid with it likewise for you know
playing piano or guitar again you have
to translate to the specific cognitive
and or motor activity that you are
seeking to improve at but
those epochs lasting 5 to 15 seconds are
really the Cornerstone of an effective
mental training and visualization
practice and the repeated nature of it
50 to 75 repetitions in a given session
is also another Cornerstone of an
effective mental training and
visualization practice so says this
review and some of the other papers that
I'm going to get to in a few moments
now one of the other key components of a
successful mental training and
visualization practice is how often you
perform that mental training and
visualization practice and again a
number of different Studies have looked
at this through a number of different
lenses meaning anywhere from two to
eight times per week
it does appear that performing these
sessions anywhere from three to five
times per week is going to be effective
we could perhaps even say most effective
because most of the uh let's just call
it the strongest data really point to
repeating these 50 to 75 Trials of the
same thing three to five times per week
so you can come up with a number that's
reasonable for you to do consistently
and you might ask do you have to
continue to perform the mental training
and visualization forever and the good
news is the answer to that question is
no it does seem that once you have
what's called Consolidated the Motor
Performance or the cognitive performance
of something it can be further supported
or reinforced that is Consolidated in
the neural circuits that are responsible
for performing that mental or physical
task so in other words once you are
performing that cognitive or motor task
in a way that's satisfactory or perhaps
just improved perhaps you're not a
hundred percent but it's improved in the
real world you don't need to continue to
do mental training and visualization to
to maintain that real world performance
so that's a good thing in fact
the ideal situation would be then to
pick a different sequence or thing that
you're trying to learn and do mental
training and visualization for that I
perhaps might have misspoke there
although I don't want to edit this out I
misspoke in the sense that again I said
for the thing that you're trying to
learn remember mental training and
visualization is going to be most
effective for building up the number of
accurate trials or that your ability to
do something with a greater frequency of
something that you're already
capable of doing or have done at least
once in the real world okay this is not
to say that mental training and
visualization can't be used to acquire
new skills it can in principle but it
has been shown to be most effective for
enhancing the speed and the accuracy of
skills that one has already demonstrated
some degree of proficiency at in the
real world I think that's important to
point out because we often hear mental
training visualization and this
equivalence of perceptual and motor
experiences in our Mind's Eye to the
real world and we think oh all we have
to do is Imagine doing something and we
will get better at it and unfortunately
that's not the case the good news is
however if you can do something once
even very slowly in the real world and
then you bring it to the mental imagery
and visualization domain you can get
much faster at it in a way that really
does translate back to the real world
I'd like to just take a brief moment and
thank one of our podcast sponsors which
is inside tracker inside tracker is a
personalized nutrition platform that
analyzes data from your blood and DNA to
help you better understand your body and
help you reach your health goals I've
long been a believer in getting regular
blood work done for the simple reason
that blood work is the only way that you
can monitor the markers such as hormone
markers lipids metabolic factors Etc the
impact your immediate and long-term
Health one major challenge with blood
work however is that most of the time it
does not come back with any information
about what to do in order to move the
values for hormones metabolic factors
lipids Etc into the ranges that you want
with inside tracker changing those
values becomes very straightforward
because it has a personalized dashboard
that you can use to address the
nutrition-based behavior-based
supplement-based approaches that you can
use in order to move those values into
the ranges that are optimal for you Your
vitality and your longevity inside
tracker now includes a measurement of
APO lipoprotein B so-called APO B in
their ultimate plan apob is a key marker
of cardiovascular health and therefore
there's extreme value to knowing your
apob levels if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can go to insidetracker.com
huberman to get 20 off any of inside
trackers plans again that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off now
if you recall principle number three or
what I'm calling principle number three
of effective mental training and
visualization which was that you have to
be able to perform
the thing that you're trying to get
better at through visualization and
imagery in the real world
that should raise the question of what
is the ratio of real world training
versus mental training that's going to
be most effective well here there's some
really interesting data not just in the
review that I mentioned but in a couple
of the other papers that we're going to
talk about in a few minutes but what
I've done is I've synthesized the
information across those papers and they
really all point to the fact that
real world training is more effective
than mental training and mental training
is more effective than no training now
the mental training more effective than
no training is kind of a duh except that
there are people for instance people who
are injured
who are trying to maintain or replenish
some motor skill or ability to move in a
particular way or who have had traumatic
brain injury and are trying to recreate
experiences in a way that's safe for
them while in a somewhat restricted
format so for instance if you've damaged
a limb or you're experiencing chronic
pain and you need to take a layoff from
some physical activity there are now
many studies looking at stroke patients
at patients that have been in accidents
TBI also people who are suffering from
more conventional limb and connective
tissue injuries that if they do mental
training it obviously is not going to
put them at risk of doing those same
movements
as it would in the real world right but
that it can actually accelerate or at
least maintain skill performance so this
is pretty exciting if you think about it
what this means and the reason it
underscores this mental training is
better than no training is that should
you find yourself in the unfortunate
circumstance of being injured or unable
to perform a given Behavior Imagining
the sequence of behavior that you'd like
to maintain or even build up over time
provided you've done that motor sequence
before in the real world well the mental
training and visualization can really
help keep that online or even help you
improve over time in fact I have a
colleague in the psychology department
at Stanford who told me an anecdote and
admittedly it's just an anecdote of a
student who was recruited to Stanford
both for their academic prowess but also
for their abilities in tennis and was
injured in their first year and at first
thought this was devastating but did a
cognitive reframe around the idea that
that let's call it extended layoff from
actual tennis was going to afford them
the ability to do more mental training
than they would otherwise even though
they were quite sad to not be able to do
actual physical training for tennis and
when they came back from that injury
they did indeed manage to improve beyond
the initial non-injured state that we're
in before the injury which is pretty
remarkable but
as Kelly pointed out to me they were
very careful to include a lot of mental
training and visualization during that
quote-unquote layoff period so again
mental training better than no training
physical training better than mental
training
but when we say physical training better
than mental training what we're really
talking about is when you allocate a
certain amount of training hours for a
given skill per week okay so how would
this look what these Studies have done
is they've said okay if people have the
option of doing the real world training
for 10 hours a week versus mental
training for 10 hours a week
which group performs better it turns out
it's the ones that do the physical
training for 10 hours per week however
we also know that combinations of
physical training and mental training
can bring about results that are greater
than either one of those alone
how would that work well I wish I could
tell you that if you did nine hours of
physical training per week plus one hour
of mental training
that your performance would be better
than if you did 10 hours of physical
training and that's not the case
okay this is why we can reliably say
physical Real World Training
and again this could be in the cognitive
domain is always going to be more
effective on an hour by hour basis
compared to mental training so if you
can do real world training and perhaps
we should be calling it real world as
opposed to physical but
if you can do real world training
compared to purely mental training
that's going to be the best use of your
time this is really important it doesn't
underscore everything that we're talking
about because
here's the really cool thing if you do
10 hours per week of real world physical
training again could be running could be
music could be math could be whatever it
is you're trying to learn shooting
basketball's hitting golf balls and you
add
one hour or even half an hour of mental
training to that real world training
well then the results are significantly
greater than you would experience with
physical training alone and of course
that would be greater than you could
achieve with mental training alone
because we already established that real
world training is more powerful in
learning skills and retaining skills
than is mental training okay if any of
that was confusing let me just say it
one more time just to be ultra clear
if you have the option to do real world
training for a cognitive indoor motor
skill versus mental training always go
with real world training however if you
can add to a maximum amount of real
world training
by doing some mental training and you
follow the principles that we've been
discussing here which are gleaned from
the scientific literature
well then you are going to get
significantly greater results in terms
of speed accuracy and consistency of
performance of those real world
behaviors and cognitive abilities
and of course if you are unable to do
physical training for whatever reason
injury
travel whatever the case may be well
then doing mental training is still
four significantly greater than doing no
training at all okay so total layoffs it
turns out are a bad thing if you want to
get better at something and indeed if
you want to retain certain skills both
cognitive and motor now a couple of
other things to keep in mind as you're
thinking about how to build up skills
through a combination of physical and
mental training
well remember back to the beginning of
the episode where we talked about
neuroplasticity and the fact that
self-directed adaptive plasticity which
is really what we're talking about here
in this entire episode things that
you're trying to learn in a deliberate
way that is as you recall a two-part
process requires focused attention both
when you're doing it in the real world
and when you're doing mental training
and it requires rest and sleep and in
fact
you would be very wise to try and get a
good night's sleep both on the days when
you do physical training again also
called real world training and mental
training you may also be asking can you
do them on the same day and this gets
into some Nuance in the literature but
by my read of the literature
here's the takeaway if you are doing the
maximum amount of physical training that
you can do according to your schedule
preventing injury and all those sorts of
important constraints and you're going
to add mental training and imagery it
doesn't really matter when you do it you
could do it immediately after your
physical training you could do it on a
separate day but you do want to place it
at a time in which you can try and get
good sleep that night so for instance
Believe It or Not Studies have been done
where people are doing mental training
at times when they should be sleeping
that is going to offset some of the
degradation and performance that you
would normally see but it's generally a
bad idea you should do your real world
training and your mental training
whenever it is that you can and then you
should try and get as much quality sleep
as you possibly can on the night
following that physical and or mental
training okay this is true of pretty
much every night of your life right if I
had my way that is if I had a magic wand
which obviously I don't I would ensure
that I and everyone else in the world
get sufficient amounts of quality sleep
every single night but that's just not
realistic there are going to be times
where that's simply not going to happen
for whatever reason and I always say if
you're not going to get sufficient
amounts of quality sleep for whatever
reason trying to make it for a fund
reason or a good reason but I think
getting sufficient amounts of quality
sleep 80 percent of the nights of your
life
is a reasonable goal and one that's
worth driving toward and we have lots of
episodes now or three really on
mastering sleep on perfecting your sleep
and uh episode guest episode with the
great Matthew Walker who wrote the book
why you why we sleep
incredibly important book all of those
as well as our toolkit for Sleep
describe ways to improve your sleep so
you can refer to those episodes if
you're having challenges with sleep and
want to improve on sleep
and things like non-sleep depressed
which can support your ability of sleep
and your ability to learn so sleep is
still vitally important not just for
ensuring neuroplasticity occurs
following real world training but also
following mental training and again when
you place that mental training is not so
critical or at least it doesn't appear
to be based on the literature so if
anyone out there has knowledge of any
peer-reviewed studies stating that
mental training should be done either
before or after or some hours away from
Real World Training please send that to
me or put in the excuse me put it in the
comments on YouTube and I'll see it
there because I do read all the comments
but I'm not aware of any any such data
or analysis and by the way if you are
interested in understanding the
relationship between motor skill
acquisition and retention and this first
night phenomenon of sleep the first
night after training versus sleep on the
second eye Etc there's a really
wonderful paper that was published by
none other than the great Matthew Walker
when I believe he was a graduate student
maybe he was a postdoc when he did this
in Robert's stick Gold's Lab at Harvard
the title of the paper is sleep and time
course of motor skill learning this is a
paper published in 2003 still an
incredibly important paper I will
provide a link to it in the show note
captions it really highlights some of
the key aspects of when people sleep and
how critical sleep is on the night
following and the nights following that
training in order to really consolidate
certain types of learning and what
phases of sleep relate to the
consolidation of motor learning Etc a
really wonderful paper and of course but
just one of Matthew and Robert stick
Gold's incredible papers on sleep and
learning remember at the beginning of
the episode when I mentioned that many
people are good at mental training and
visualization but some people are not
well sex differences have been explored
and age-related differences have been
explored in terms of people's ability to
mentally visualize and train up specific
skills and while initially there were
some sex differences identified really
the bulk of the subsequent literature
that is the majority of quality
peer-reviewed studies on this aspect of
mental training visualization point to
the fact that there are no significant
differences between males and females in
terms of their ability to mentally
visualize nor their ability to use that
mental visualization toward improving
cognitive or motor skills that point was
covered in some detail in the review I
mentioned earlier best practice for
motor imagery a systematic literature
view on motor imagery training elements
in five different disciplines this
review also looked at age-related
effects and perhaps the only thing that
really popped out from this literature
review in terms of age-dependent
differences that point to changes in
protocols that you might make is that
for individuals 65 or older a
combination of physical and mental
training may actually allow them
to gain and consolidate skills better
than were they to do physical training
alone now whether or not that's due to
some
lower upper limit of physical training
that they can do because of their age or
whether or not that's something specific
to do with older versus younger neural
circuits isn't clear
but what this review also makes clear is
that for the vast majority of people out
there so teens people in their 20s
in their 40s and so on physical training
more effective than mental training we
said that before combination of physical
and mental training more effective
than physical training alone provided
the mental training is on top of the
maximum amount of physical training that
one could do and of course mental
training more effective than no training
at all okay so we talked about sets and
Reps we talked about you know five to
Fifteen second epochs with about 15
second breaks in between
or rest between sets if you will repeat
it for 50 to 75 trials done three to
five times per week
some of the conditions of keeping it
really simple The Importance of Being
able to actually perform those sequences
in the real world and so on what we
haven't discussed is first person versus
third person and eyes open versus eyes
closed so what are we really talking
about here well first person mental
training and visualization would be
where you are imagining doing something
and you are seeing yourself doing
something from the inside out as opposed
from the outside in Imagine for instance
wearing a headcam okay or a body Cam and
doing something with your hands
or being in virtual reality and having
the sense that whatever you see in front
of you and that's moving and that you're
doing that's you so what I mean by this
is a mental training or visualization
protocol for instance if you were at the
piano or at a guitar where you're
actually looking down at or sensing the
feeling of your hands but you're not
actually moving your hands okay as
opposed to seeing yourself from outside
of your body so looking at yourself say
standing next to you or from across the
room you're looking at yourself playing
the piano or playing guitar or swinging
a golf club or doing a tennis serve okay
first person versus third person
and what the data tell us is that first
person mental training and visualization
is generally more effective than third
which perhaps raises another course of
does out there but it needn't have been
the case right I mean you could imagine
that seeing yourself doing something and
doing it perfectly because you've done
it perfectly once before hopefully would
allow you to build up that skill more
quickly because you have that third
person perspective where you can really
see every aspect in every element of
what you're trying to perform
Well turns out that the first person
mental training and visualization is
significantly more effective than that
third person mental training and
visualization so if what you're trying
to learn lends itself well to this first
person mental experiencing of self as
you perform the cognitive and or motor
skill I suggest you do that as opposed
to the third person version
now what if what you're trying to learn
doesn't lend itself well to first person
visualization for instance what if
you're trying to learn uh specific
cognitive skill that doesn't involve any
overt motor Behavior to be observed well
in that case it's very clear that
closing your eyes ideally and trying to
perform that specific cognitive task or
the statement or the you know uttering
of a particular sentence in another
language or doing some sort of
computation or problem solving of some
sort in your head well that itself of
course is first person because it's
inside your own body as opposed to and I
don't know that anyone would actually do
this but looking at yourself from a
third person perspective in your mind's
eye and seeing yourself perform that
cognitive
challenge whatever that challenge may
happen to be okay now we have to address
eyes open versus eyes closed and this is
where the literature gets pretty
interesting I always thought for some
reason I don't know why but I presumed
that mental training and visualization
should always be done eyes closed but it
turns out that's not how a lot of
studies of mental training and
visualization have been done in fact
many of them have arrived at really
impressive protocols which are
essentially the protocols that I've
distilled out and I'm listing out during
today's episode
having people either watch videos of
themselves performing a given skill and
imagining themselves in that role and
again it's them so again during the
mental training visualization they're
watching a movie of themselves so
they're somewhat in the third person
perspective I guess we could technically
say they are in the third person
perspective but they're watching
themself so in doing that we know based
on neuroimaging studies that when we
watch videos of ourselves doing things
we experience that more from a
first-person perspective than if we
watch videos of other people doing
things use your imagination here folks
so
if you're somebody for instance who's
trying to get better at a particular
skill this could be not just sport but
also public speaking watching videos of
yourself doing that can be very
effective but of course we have to come
back to the first principle of effective
mental training and visualization which
is that whatever it is that we're trying
to build up or consolidate as a skill
needs to be brief and repeated so what
we're really talking about here is
watching a video of ourselves on Loop or
listening to a audio or audio video
recording of ourselves on Loop for
whatever aspect that we're trying to
build up or improve upon now for people
that for instance are trying to get
better at dealing with public speaking
and there isn't a particular skill or
utterance of particular sentences or
words that they're trying to accomplish
but rather they're trying to learn to be
more relaxed or to articulate better in
the public speaking scenario there would
be one of the few instances in which I
suggest more General theme and not exact
recapitulation of some specific words
that you're going to say perhaps it
could be a sequence of you walking out
onto stage
toward the podium or out from the podium
and facing the audience and looking in
multiple directions up and down to see
people in every corner of the room and
just repeating that on Loop in your
mind's eye or watching yourself do that
on video and making yourself calm in
your internal State as you're doing that
this is more of mental autonomic
training because what you're really
trying to do is control your autonomic
nervous system the nervous system aspect
that controls how alert or calm you are
as opposed to a specific skill however
you could also translate this to you
know dance steps or to motor sequences
for playing an instrument
and so on so the point here is that it's
not as if there is zero utility to third
person mental training and visualization
there can be but
first person mental training
visualization is going to be more
effective as I mentioned before and if
you're going to use the third person
mental training visualization ideally
you would be looking at yourself either
on video or listening to yourself in
audio and or video
that is going to be more effective than
closing your eyes and trying to imagine
yourself from a third person perspective
in your mind's eye okay so just to make
it really simple first person better
than third person visualization if
you're going to go with third person
visualization try and go with real third
person visualization where you're
actually seeing and or hearing yourself
on a screen and again this was somewhat
of a surprise to me I always thought
that mental training and visualization
was done with eyes closed I thought okay
could you close your eyes you imagine
this you imagine that that's actually
not the case for many many studies some
of which are considered real Hallmark
studies within the field of mental
training and visualization and the
different neural circuits that it
recruits and along those lines there's a
really interesting study it came out not
that long ago this was just a summer of
2022. like to discuss in a little bit of
detail because it really hammers home a
number of the principles that we talked
about the title of the article is mental
practice modulates functional
connectivity between the cerebellum and
the primary motor cortex
I'm going to tell you the essential
features of this study first of all
primary motor cortex
sometimes called M1 is a relatively
small but vitally important strip of
neurons in or near the front of your
brain
the neurons there are called upper motor
neurons they communicate through a set
of neural connections with what are
called lower motor neurons the lower
motor neurons sit in What's called the
ventral Horn of the spinal cord so along
the spinal cord you have sensory inputs
coming from skin and muscle and what's
called proprioceptive feedback that
tells you where your limbs are in
relation to each other and to yourself
and so on you also have motor neurons
that live in the spinal cord they're
actually the ones that send little wires
that we call axons out to the muscles
release acetylcholine onto those muscles
and allow those muscles to contract
lower motor neurons are the ones that
actually generate movement however
they are largely responsible for
reflexive movements are already learned
movements and they require some input
from things like Central pattern
generators and some other circuits
within the spinal cord and brain stem
but it's those M1 primary motor cortex
neurons that are called upper motor
neurons because they control lower motor
neurons
through directed action okay
so when I say primary motor cortex I'm
really talking about those upper motor
neurons M1 the cerebellum is an area in
the back of your brain if you were to
look at a brain you'd see two little
lobes back there that are highly
foliated foliated means that lots of
lots of folds and lots of bumps and
grooves back there and actually means
mini brain it looks like a kind of a
mini brain stuffed in the back of the
brain
in certain animals the cerebellum is
much larger than the rest of the brain
in humans the cerebellum is relatively
small compared to the rest of the
so-called neocortex the outer shell the
human brain the cerebellum is involved
in Balance it's also involved in eye
movements it's also involved in timing
and motor learning and the key thing to
understand is that the cerebellum
communicates with the primary motor
cortex and it can do so through what's
called inhibition it has outputs that
inhibit the activity of neurons in the
motor cortex and elsewhere and that has
a profound influence on the execution of
motor Behavior and the learning of
particular motor behaviors now I don't
want to get into too much detail around
all this but what you need to know is
that the cerebellum communicates with M1
primary motor cortex M1 is primary motor
cortex so the upper motor neurons that
are going to control that lower murder
neurons and are going to control
physical behavior and execution of
physical movements
the communication between cerebellum and
primary motor cortex
is inhibitory although it can activate
motor cortex too and this gets into a
little bit of technical detail but there
can be inhibition of inhibition so if
you take something that's a break and
you inhibit that break what you end up
with is more excitation okay so the
takeaway here that's key and everyone
should be able to understand even though
you may or may not be following this
whole cerebellum primary motor cortex
thing is that when we gain a new skill
or we get more proficient at a skill so
faster and more accurate there tends to
be more net excitation of the cerebellum
to motor cortex communication and that
is accomplished by reducing inhibition
so that's where it gets a little bit
confusing to some but in this paper what
they did is they explored people's
ability to improve on a very specific
but very simple motor sequence it's one
that you're already familiar with it's
that tapping sequence that I talked
about before where the thumb is digit
one index finger number two middle
finger number three
ring finger number four and pinky finger
number five and it's a one two one three
one four one five one two one three one
four one five and they had people
actually perform this and they measured
their speed and accuracy and then they
had them do a practice session that was
either an intentional task so one group
just looked at an intentional cue and
had to maintain uh focus on that
attentional cue and another group did
mental practice they basically did 50
imagined trials so just in their Mind's
Eye of this one two one three one four
one five on repeat okay 50 trials much
in the same way as what I referenced as
the ideal protocol earlier okay 50
rounds of that then they got tested
again on the motor task in the real
world
and there were also recordings of the
cerebellar to primary motor cortex
communication so there were a bunch of
different results in this study I think
are interesting but the ones that are
most important are that quote we found
that mental practice enhanced both the
speed and accuracy of this one two one
three one four one five performance in
the real world when people did these 50
imagine trials there are many results
out there different papers that
parallel and essentially say the same
thing as what is said in this paper and
remember there have been studies of
mental training dating back to the 1880s
but what this paper really does it looks
at the neural machinery and the changes
in the neural machinery and what they
found using transcranial magnetic
stimulation both in the context of
stimulating but also recording activity
and connectivity between cerebellum and
primary motor cortex is that mental
training enhanced the net excitation of
cerebellum to motor cortex communication
that is it reduced the inhibition in a
way that allowed motor cortex to
generate these movements with more
accuracy and more speed what's also
interesting about this paper is that it
showed that the Improvement in
performance of this task was not related
to activation of the motor pathways
themselves so it's not the case that the
cerebellum activation or inhibition
changed the patterns of excitation going
directly to the spinal cord
because those Pathways actually exist
through a couple of intermediate
stations what it really showed is that
when people do mental training and here
you could say Okay 50 trials that's a
lot of Trials but it's not actually that
many trials it's pretty fast learning if
you think about do a task in the real
world do 50 Trials of the Imagine task
do the trial in the real world again
significant Improvement in speed and
accuracy through now what are becoming
to be established neural circuit
connections between cerebellum and
primary motor cortex okay so this study
is one of several but not a tremendous
number of studies out there that are
starting to really pinpoint the
underlying neural circuits that allow
mental training and visualization to
really improve motor skill performance
but again and please hear me on this
in this study and in the vast majority
of other studies that have shown
significant Improvement in Motor
Performance in the real world by use of
mental training visualization there was
an ability of each and everyone in the
study to perform the specific motor
sequence in the real world that then
they were able to enhance with mental
training and visualization now thus far
we've been talking mostly about
performance of motor sequences and one
of the things to really understand about
performance of motor sequences both in
the real world and in the Imagine
context is that it involves the doing
that's what we call a go
action and not doing certain things what
I mean by not doing well for many tasks
out there even ones as simple as the one
two one three one four one five task
that we talked about a moment ago
there is the need not just to tap those
fingers in the correct sequence as
quickly as possible but also to be
accurate about it to not do one three
one four or one three and four at the
same time so there's both a go component
an action component and a withhold
action component and the ability to
withhold action is strongly constrained
by the time domain in other words the
faster that we need to perform a given
motor sequence the more likely we are to
perform incorrect components of the
motor sequence as well okay so one of
the key things about mental training and
visualization that's really remarkable
is that it can also be used and has been
shown to improve not just go aspects of
Motor Performance and cognitive
performance but also no go
aspects of Motor Performance and skill
learning now the go no go thing is
something I've discussed before on this
podcast in reference to the so-called
basal ganglia basal ganglia are
subcortical so they're below that bumpy
surface of the human brain that we're
most accustomed to seeing when we look
at it from the outside
and the basal ganglia are strongly
involved in Go versus no go type tasks
and learning now
there are only a few studies that have
really looked at the learning and the
Improvement of no go components of motor
learning but these no-go components are
really really important in fact if we
were to look at what's involved at
Improvement in a golf swing or shooting
free throws or getting better at piano
or getting better at math or language
speaking
I think it's fair to say that at least
half and probably as much as 75 percent
of motor learning is about restricting
inappropriate movements or utterances or
thoughts if what you're trying to learn
is purely cognitive okay I think that's
an important point that brings us back
to our initial learning when we come
into this world that developmental
plasticity which as you recall we have a
lot of interconnected aspects of our
brain and nervous system early in life
remember the example of the kid trying
to eat and getting the spoon of food and
Bowl on their head Etc
and then over time getting more accurate
at bringing food to their mouth and
eating in a clean way things that most
but not all people accomplish in at some
point in the course of their lifetime
well there haven't been many but there
have been a few very interesting studies
looking at how mental training and
visualization can improve the no-go
aspect of motor learning and I think
this is important to highlight because
it really mirrors What's Done in the
real world as opposed to just the finger
tapping type things which are mostly go
tasks again there's a little bit of a
no-go component there but there are
specific tasks that people have
developed for the laboratory that really
closely mimic action learning and
cognitive learning in the real world and
one of the more
important of those is What's called the
stop signal task now the stop signal
task is something that I'll explain to
you I'll also provide a link in the show
note caption so you can try it it's
actually a lot of fun to try this
because it really gives you a sense of
just how challenging some of these
laboratory tasks are let me just
describe it for a moment the stop signal
task was really developed and
popularized by Gordon Logan and William
Cowan Gordon Logan is at Vanderbilt
University and has done a lot of really
important work but one of the important
aspects of his work is looking at Motor
Performance and skill acquisition and
the development of the stop signal task
I'll describe the stop signal task for
you now in Broad Contour you or another
research subject would sit in front of a
screen there are two keys on that
keyboard or two keys among the other
keys on that keyboard one which is
designated left the other which is
designated right and then on the screen
you'll be presented for instance with a
left-facing or a right-facing arrow so
in the initial trial what would happen
is that Arrow would pop up on the screen
and your job is to press the left key
when the right facing arrow is presented
you press the right key okay pretty
straightforward but there's a limited
amount of time in which you can do this
and the idea is that you're going to
need to do this within approximately 500
milliseconds of the presentation of that
Arrow or else it's going to tell you
that you missed that trial now of course
if you press the wrong key so if the
arrow goes left and you press the right
key then you would be told you got that
one wrong okay so this is a reaction
time test and not one that's
particularly novel what's novel and what
Logan and Cowan developed was that in
the stop signal task
every once in a while not every trial
but every once in a while that arrow is
presented and then with some delay
ranging from anywhere from 100
milliseconds to maybe 350 milliseconds
there will be a red circle or a red X
also presented which is a stop signal
and your job is to not press the key
that corresponds to the direction of
arrow in fact not press any key at all
now you can imagine how if the stop
signal shows up with a longer delay
after the presentation of the arrow
there's a higher probability that you
will have already generated the key
pressing movement okay so at the link
that we provide in the show note caption
you can actually do these two tasks and
what you'll find is that you and most
people will be able to do this Arrow to
Reaction Time pressing of the left to
right key somewhere in the neighborhood
between 300 milliseconds and maybe as
long as 500 millisecond delay you'll get
an average of how quickly you respond
and then of course if you choose to and
I would hope you would choose to go on
and do the stop signal task
you will be told trial by trial whether
or not you are hitting the right keys
because if you are you'll be allowed to
progress to the next trial or if you are
told to stop
that is you get the stop signal and you
press the key anyway you'll be told that
you made an error because you did not
stop now again with very short delays
between the presentation of the arrow
and the stop signal you are going to be
much better at inhibiting or preventing
yourself from the behavior at the no go
aspect of motor execution that is what
you will find is that if the stop signal
is presented very shortly after let's
say 100 milliseconds which is very very
brief amount of time after the
presentation of the arrow there's a good
chance that you're going to be able to
withhold the
key pressing behavior however if the
delay is anywhere from 200 to 350
milliseconds after the presentation of
the arrow chances are that you're going
to press the button even when you
shouldn't have on at least some of those
trials okay and if you try and game the
system and wait a certain amount of time
after the presentation of each Arrow
there will also be times in which the
stop signal does not appear and you fail
to hit the button in the appropriate
amount of time so it's a fun little task
it doesn't cost anything or except maybe
a couple of minutes of your time and if
you do have time to go to it I think um
it will give you a much deeper flavor
for the sorts of experiments that we're
talking about here and that you find
that these stop signals are actually
pretty hard to generate when you're
trying to learn some new motor behavior
and that actually illustrates a bigger
Point here if today you sense that we've
been talking about studies of you know
tapping fingers and you know stopping
button presses and that those examples
are highly artificial and don't really
translate to the real world well keep in
mind that the tasks that are used in
these studies really Target the specific
neural circuits that is the same neural
circuit that you would use for the
performance of essentially any motor
task now of course other motor tasks
like ones where you involve your feet or
cognitive tasks where you have to think
really hard about specific information
and search for that information assemble
it in particular ways of course involve
other neurons and neural circuits that
we haven't discussed today but the core
components of these go and no-go tasks
are the stop signal tasks really capture
the core elements of most all of
cognitive and or motor learning in some
way that's fundamentally important okay
so they have real world relevance
the paper that I'd like to just briefly
describe to you is entitled motor
imagery combined with physical training
improves response inhibition in the stop
signal task okay so that title is a
little bit wordy but now you know what
the stop signal task is
and what this paper essentially found
was that if people did physical training
so the sort of experiment that I just
described versus mental training where
they sat eyes open and imagined their
responses to those arrows and stop
signals but they didn't actually
generate any key presses versus a
combination of the physical training so
the actual pressing of the buttons or
withholding pressing of the buttons as
the case may be plus mental training
over the course of about five days using
the Contour described of the key
principles of mental training
performance we've talked about I'll get
to the specifics in a moment but it
really obeyed most all of what we've
talked about if not all of it so
repetition simple repeated over about
five days and so on and so forth what
they found was that the mental training
and physical training group so mental
and real world training groups
performed significantly better in the
stop signal reaction time that is they
were able to withhold action when they
needed to withhold action
more frequently and with more accuracy
than did either the physical training or
mental training groups alone so this
actually
fits in the face of what we said earlier
which is that physical training is
always better than mental training and
mental training is always better than no
training and it's important to point out
here that both the physical training and
the mental training groups experience
significant improvements in their
reaction time and accuracy at the stop
signal task but in the case of this
study which is exploring the withholding
of inappropriate behaviors
the combination of mental training and
physical training outperformed either
physical or mental training alone so
while earlier we said that if you have a
certain amount of time in order to train
something up physical training is always
going to be better than mental training
well here we have somewhat of an
exception where if the thing you're
trying to learn involves withholding
mistakes
as opposed to trying to generate the
right behaviors per se well then
you are probably better off doing a
combination of mental training and
physical training let me state that a
little bit differently if you're finding
that you're screwing up
something not because you can't initiate
that particular motor Behavior but
you're doing the wrong thing at the
wrong time you're not able to withhold a
particular action well then in that case
mental training in combination with
physical training becomes especially
important so for you coaches for you
students out there keep that in mind
when trying to learn how to withhold
particular action sequences because
they're not serving you well in the real
world
using a combination of
real world training and physical
training is actually better for you on
an hour per hour basis than is physical
training alone a couple of key details
about this study should you decide to
implement these protocols in this study
they did approximately 30 Trials of the
thing that they were trying to get
better at now they did those in the real
world so in this case the stop signal
task involved actually pressing those
buttons and then they had a test phase
of about
144 go trials and about 48 stop trials
okay so this is important if you are a
coach or you're a student or you're just
going to self-direct this kind of
learning in your self-directed adaptive
plasticity it's important that you mix
in both go and no go trials okay it
wasn't always the case that there was a
stop signal generated
the other thing that was really
impressive about the study is that the
changes occurred very quickly so the
training was performed five times over
five days so once a day for five days
again back to this three to five times
per week principle and
the improvements were really significant
in some cases in fact if you decide to
peruse this paper you can go to
um you know table two you can see you
know in some cases a near doubling in
the reduction in reaction time through a
combination of mental and physical
training compared to physical training
alone or mental training alone again
however
both physical training and mental
training groups alone saw significant
improvements but the combination of
mental training and physical training
was far greater than you saw with either
one of those alone so that's all nicely
Quantified for you in this paper so
again I really like this paper despite
it not involving a huge number of
subjects I think it is a key paper
because it really points to
such an important element of motor
learning and training which is this
action withholding component this no-go
component that here is captured so
nicely in the stop signal task so before
we round up our discussion about motor
training and visualization I want to
just briefly touch on some of the
studies that have explored why certain
individuals are better or worse at motor
training and visualization and what that
might correlate with at the beginning of
today's episode I briefly mentioned
affantasia which is this phenomenon
where some people just simply
can't or seem to have extreme Challenge
generating visual imagery there's been a
number of studies exploring how
aphantasics as they're sometimes called
although
nowadays it's um not considered polite
if you will to refer to people according
to their condition so for instance
propasagnosia is a condition in which
people are unable to recognize
particular faces
and in the past these people were
referred to as pro-pastagnosis okay as
if their condition defined them uh right
um nowadays it's not considered polite
to do that rather we say the person has
professed agnosia or suffers from
proposed signosia although the words
suffer then also has become a little bit
touchy I'm going to do my best to just
try and be as clear as possible here and
explain that people who have aphantasia
can have a Fantasia to varying degrees
so they can either have a complete
absence of ability to generate mental
imagery or they have a poor or kind of
rudimentary ability to generate visual
imagery in their Mind's Eye
it was thought that people who have
aphantasia are not capable of what's
called synesthesia synesthesias or when
people have perceptual blending and this
is not well under the influence of any
kind of psychedelic or other kind of
drug
perceptual blending of an atypical kind
or rare kind I actually have some
friends I have two friends that have
different forms of synesthesia One
Associates different keys on the piano
or musical notes with specific colors in
a very very one-to-one specific way so
they'll tell you that E flat on the
piano is a particular tone in their mind
of of Amber Hugh okay and that
I forget what other key is associated
with a particular shade of red and so on
and so forth are these people better at
piano are they more perceptive of colors
in their environment not necessarily so
this is just a perceptual blending it
doesn't necessarily lend itself to any
improved ability now you could imagine
why people would hypothesize that people
have aphantasia especially it's extreme
form would not be capable
of or have synesthesias but it turns out
that's not the case there are a couple
of really interesting papers again we
will link these in the show note
captions
um one is entitled what is the
relationship between aphantasia
synesthesia and autism
and the other one is aphantasia the
science of visual imagery extremes and I
really like the review at Fantasia the
science of visual imagery extremes for
those of you that are interested in
understanding aphantasia with more depth
the study addressing the relationship
between aphantasia synesthesia and
autism found that
aphantasia is indeed linked to weak
visual imagery but
that advantages can also be synesthetics
and vice versa
what was also interesting about this
study is they addressed the question of
whether or not people who have
aphantasia that is a challenge or
inability to generate mental or visual
imagery tend to have features associated
with autism or residing somewhere on the
autism spectrum and I'm not trying to
use ambiguous language here but the
whole set of language in nomenclature
around autism and autism spectrum is
also undergoing revision now because we
are now coming to understand that
autism
and nowadays it's generally not
considered correct to call people
autistics in that sense but autism is
considered one set of positions along a
spectrum that includes things like
Asperger's Etc but that may also include
other aspects of cognition and even
personality so these are starting to be
viewed not just as a spectrum or one
Continuum ranging from you know
non-autistic to autistic but a lot of
variation in subtlety in between and
even crossing over with other aspects of
Personality Psychology and Neuroscience
okay so I'm not trying to be vague here
I'm trying to be accurate rather by
saying the whole description and
categorization of autistic non-autistic
Etc is undergoing vast revision right
now but the important point I think from
this paper is that indeed it was found
that people who have a Fantasia tend to
exhibit more of the features that are
associated with the autism spectrum now
how those things relate to one another
in terms of their clinical relevance
isn't clear and of course it is entirely
unclear as to what's the chicken and
what's the egg there so you could
imagine no pun intended for instance
that people that are on the autism
spectrum might be less proficient at
generating visual imagery because they
are exceedingly proficient at other
things you could also imagine that
people are placed onto the autism
spectrum as it's sometimes referred to
or are associated with particular
features on the autism spectrum because
in a causal way of the aphantasia and of
course it's extremely important to
highlight that not all people that
consider themselves or that people
consider Autistic or that are on the
autism spectrum or Asperger's or any
variation thereof necessarily have a
Fantasia just as it is that not all
people that are on the autism spectrum
completely lack or even lack what's
called theory of mind which is the
ability to sort of empathize And
subscribe
feelings and motivations of others when
viewing the actions and perceived
feelings of others okay so what I just
described hopefully doesn't come across
as just a bunch of word soup what I'm
trying to pinpoint is that there does
seem to be a relationship between one's
ability to generate visual imagery and
certain constellations of cognitive and
emotional perception and behavior and
vice versa okay
in a future episode I promise to cover
synesthesia and autism and some of the
related
cognitive and motor aspects of autism
and things like Asperger's I'm going to
feature an expert guess or actually
several expert guests in this area
because it is a rapidly evolving and
somewhat controversial field meanwhile I
think it's important to at least
consider how mental training and
visualization might relate to certain
aspects of cognition and our ability to
visualize things not just in terms of
other people's behavior which is one of
the common ways that people probe for
autism and Asperger's versus
non-autistic and non-aspergers and so on
the so-called theory of Mind task in
effect asking whether or not children or
adults can really get in the mind of
others that's a typical task developed
by Simon Baron Cohen
but also whether or not children and
adults are capable of generating mental
imagery in a really Vivid way or whether
or not they have minor or even extreme
Challenge in doing so and perhaps the
most direct way to explain why I
included this aspect of the discussion
of mental training and visualization as
it relates to different cognitive
phenotypes or neurocognitive phenotypes
such as autism Asperger's Etc is because
if you think about motor skill execution
or cognitive skill execution and the
relationship between mental training and
visualization and motor skills or
cognitive skills that's all pretty
straightforward when you're talking
about finger tapping and go no-go tasks
and learning piano and things of that
sort but in many many ways our learning
of social cognition our learning of how
to behave in certain circumstances
what's considered normal or atypical
neurotypical and neuroatypical if you
will a lot of that is not just generated
from the inside out but it also involves
observation and visualization of what
are considered appropriate and
inappropriate definitely placed in
quotes by the way folks I'm not placing
judgment I'm just saying appropriate and
inappropriate for a given context
behavior in other words social learning
and social cognition is every bit as
much a learned behavior and pattern of
cognitive and motor patterns as is
tapping fingers or withholding key
presses in a go no-go task it's just
that it transmits into a domain that
involves smiling versus frowning versus
asking a question versus staying silent
versus sitting still versus fidgeting
what's appropriate and when what's
inappropriate and when all of that is
what we call social cognition and has
direct parallels to everything we've
been talking about up until this point
so today we did a deep dive which is
often the case on this podcast into
mental training and visualization
during the course of the episode I tried
to lay down one by one the key
components of an effective mental
training and visualization practice
everything ranging from making sure that
the practice involves brief epochs
repeats of specific sequences of motor
and or cognitive behavior that those be
relatively simple so that you can
imagine them even if you're somebody
who's not good at doing mental training
and visualization and I should mention
that if you do mental training and
visualization repeatedly over time you
get better at mental training and
visualization there's a what's called
metaplasticity here so it's not just
about engaging neuroplasticity of
particular circuits it's also about
getting better at engaging plasticity so
plasticity of plasticity
I also describe the key Importance of
Being able to actually execute specific
movements and cognitive tasks in the
real world if you want the mental
training and visualization to be
especially effective and we talked about
the importance of naming things we
talked about the importance of creating
not just one but many parallels between
real world training and mental training
and visualization and really on the
whole what we established was that
cognitive and or motor learning really
is something that you should do in the
real world as much as possible but if
you can't due to injury or whatever
conditions
using mental training is a reasonable
substitute but not a complete substitute
and if you can't do real world training
for whatever reason injury or otherwise
that mental training is going to be
better than no training at all
and of course we established that at
least four withholding action in order
to get better at a skill a combination
of physical training and mental training
is going to be best but that if you're
trying to learn a new skill and you're
having challenges with performing that
skill because of an inability to do the
skill in the first place or on a
consistent basis well then on an
hour-by-hour basis you're best off
investing your time into the physical
training only incorporating mental
training and visualization if you are
able to do that on top of the maximum
amount of real world training that
you're capable of doing and of course we
talked about the actual neural circuits
and a bit about how the actual
neuroplasticity occurs early in the
episode I mentioned long-term depression
well in describing the improvements in
no-go tasks those stop signal tasks a
lot of what's observed during those
tasks is an improvement or rather an
increase in long-term depression of
specific neural connections so my hope
is that in learning about those basic
neural circuits and plasticity
mechanisms
and in learning about the critical
importance of focus and attention during
learning both real world and imagined as
well as the importance of sleep and deep
rest for really consolidating learning
and the different tools the various
steps or principles of effective mental
training and visualization that you now
have a fairly coherent or maybe even a
very coherent picture of how to develop
the best mental training and
visualization protocols for you I
realize that everyone has different
goals everyone has different time
constraints if you are somebody that's
interested in developing a mental
training and visualization protocol so
if you're a coach or teacher or simply a
learner or you're trying to self-direct
your own adaptive plasticity I want to
emphasize that the key components that
we discussed today are essential to
include but I wouldn't obsess about
whether or not a given Epoch is 15 or 20
seconds or even 25 seconds I wouldn't
obsess over whether or not you got 30
repetitions in and then your mind
drifted or whether or not you could do
the full 50 to 75 or whether or not even
in your mind's eye you made some errors
what's been shown over and over again in
this literature is that performing
mental training and visualization
repeatedly and in a very restricted way
that makes it easier to perform those
trials over and over and over again and
with a high degree of accuracy
almost always
really we can fairly say and essentially
every study where it's been explored has
led to improvements in real world
performance of both cognitive and or
physical tasks so if you're trying to
learn anything at all I do encourage you
to explore motor training and
visualization because basically all the
studies out there
in fact I couldn't find one exception
where some degree of improvement wasn't
observed when people use motor training
and visualization on a consistent basis
even just the three to five times per
week these simple repeats over and over
so I don't want to over complicate or
make it sound like mental training and
visualization has to be performed in a
very precise way or that it has to be
done perfectly each and every time quite
to the contrary what is clear is that
mental training and visualization is a
very effective way to improve real world
performance if you're learning from and
or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our YouTube channel that's
a terrific zero cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on both Spotify and apple and on
both Spotify and apple you can leave us
up to a five-star review
if you have questions for us or comments
about the podcast or guess you'd like me
to feature on the huberman Lab podcast
please put those in the comments section
on YouTube I do read all the comments
please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support the huberman Lab
podcast not so much on today's episode
but on many previous episodes of The
uberman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like improving sleep for hormone
augmentation and for improving Focus the
huberman Lab podcast is proud to have
partnered with momentous supplements if
you'd like to learn more about the
supplements discussed on the huberman
Lab podcast please go to live momentous
spelledous.com slash huberman again
that's libomentis.com huberman if you're
not already following huberman lab on
social media I am huberman lab on
LinkedIn Facebook Twitter and Instagram
and at all those places I cover content
some of which overlaps with the content
of the huberman Lab podcast but much of
which is distinct from content on the
huberman Lab podcast so again it's
huberman lab all social media platforms
also I know many of you are interested
in summaries of podcasts and what we
call tool kits which describe ideal
toolkits and protocols for sleep or
ideal toolkit and protocols for
neuroplasticity for deliberate cold
exposure etc for that reason we've
established What's called the neural
network newsletter this is a completely
zero cost newsletter that you can sign
up for by going to hubermanlab.com go to
the menu
scroll down to newsletter and you sign
up by providing your email we do not
share your email with anybody and there
are also some sample PDFs of existing
huberman Lab podcast protocols again
ranging from neuroplasticity to sleep
and other topics that we've covered in
brief one to three page summaries thank
you once again for joining me for
today's discussion all about the science
and effective implementation of mental
training and visualization and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]